hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I know this
would be crazy we're gonna check out a
video today part 5 part 5 - don't hug me
I'm scared you know like these videos
are interesting I was listening to an
interview of the creators and they were
talking about how these videos are meant
to be open to interpretation like their
only real meaning was show someone how
to not teach someone how to do something
that's what I basically gather from what
they said some people are like no buts
about this but the truth is they're like
no it's totally open to interpretation
whatever you get from it is what we're
gonna discuss today right I just try not
to like I try not to watch them because
I find them oddly unsettling and I don't
particularly enjoy that I'm sorry but
but I've seen them let's do this then
hmm something different
hmm something's missing someone's gonna
come in for a musical number the red
dudes missing
is it this guy no what's your body
hungry comes from your body me
what's your body it must have to be
healthy greedy to eat all that you'll
end up with your teeth all grey food is
talking let's get helping out
body is like a special house with blood
hair and organs in the different rooms
oh look there's mr. bladder in the
basement and our food comes in through
the chimney mouth and goes from room to
room greeting the different organ I know
now the good healthy food is very nice
and polite to the organs and so is
invited to stay for a party yay but the
bad not healthy foods are very rude and
must leave through the cat flap healthy
like that crazy to eat all box you'll
end up with you gums all gray how do we
know which one to the healthy foods to
eat well that's easy the world groups
can easily be sorted using the simple
health chase choosing normal blend
looking foods at your bread free white
sauce and aspic keep the body ticking
over just nicely isn't that right wait
what these fancy Shelby foods like
cooked meats fruit salad soil foods and
yo these foods clog up the body with
unnecessary detail of God knows our
happen located on the show ring could be
what the [ __ ] is going on this is really
weird
you're better off with play twice or
what's that plain white sauce plain
white sauce makes your teeth go grey
doesn't matter just throw it away why
not try something else on your tray oh
what's that
a lot right but you're gonna end up sad
inside everyone has a deed go grey just
be yeast and it'll go away how much if
you have today to watch these Mickey so
great was the community sufficiently
food for the strangers plates changes
place changes plate strangers strangers
strangers
huh
Wow hey the red guys walking he left
[ __ ] what but I sort of get the
concept of it of like they're making
fine I get I feel like they're making
fun of how the most minimal basic
education won't really educate you at
all so they're making fun of like I
think that's why they use puppets
because it's such basic information meet
his friends yeah no but I like the dark
turns I don't know it's like it's kind
of like scaring a child into not doing
it this way I don't know I'm just trying
to support them I know I don't know I
like these videos I get what they're
doing and I appreciate how they do it
but I feel like I just dropped acid yeah
no it does have that vibe and I think
that's part of the joke to them is like
they know it's just creeping out a lot
of people and it's so unsettling yeah
it's so unsettling but they makes them
laugh you know I know what it's like to
have a sense of humor like that I'm
saying I don't have a sense of humor no
I'm saying that sometimes making people
uncomfortable is this funny it can be
funny
excuse me
it can be really funny sometimes hey our
legs are touching each other they are
you're right if you're trying to make
them comfortable this is not how you do
that that's how you do that like am I
really going this far to try to make
here it is underwear next to be it I'm
not at all comfortable I think we didn't
know each other surprise - sort of see
me naked before so I don't how we did
that Alyssa Fool's Day video anyway back
to the topic of the video I don't know I
like kind of the twisted sense of humor
they have I get the joke so much yeah
that I I can't help but find it funny
cuz I'm like yeah they're succeeding and
it makes them laugh to know that like
someone like me is getting grossed out I
mean you get grossed out and I get
uncomfortable like whatever they're
going for it's working yeah but at the
end of day it's always like a feeling
that's like it's never like I made me
feel really good oh it's it's it always
sort of like a darker feeling and I like
that they find that funny that people
are responding that way is I think it's
like oddly satisfying and it looks fun
at the fact that these kind of like
puppets and shake can be freaky oh yeah
totally like okay here's I don't know if
you know this about me Muppets can't do
it can't do it can't watch Muppets they
freak me out like they they are one of
my worst fears and I think that's why
this makes me so uncomfortable to a
degree because they're not exactly
Muppets but they're they're in the same
yeah so I feel like whenever it takes
that dart turn towards the end it's a
simple set of it usually goes oh these
guys are doing something ordinary then a
third fourth character comes in and they
started breaking into a musical number
right then it seems like a simple
educational video then it takes a super
dark turn oh yeah and that's like the
basic you know beat of how these videos
work and I feel like what the same thing
there's making fun of of how like
puppets like this can be creepy and what
the [ __ ] do they really behave like and
[ __ ] that's what I get from it and you
know it's open to interpretation I feel
like it really feeds on the human psyche
of even though you should eat healthy
you know
you don't want to yeah and most of the
time it doesn't happen but you can't
believe me is not a thing that happens
as a result wrong
Rob oh I'm sorry cannibalism is great I
eat [ __ ] all the time I hear people
taste like bacon it does not taste like
bacon
I've heard it does it taste like licking
a rose yeah I'm actually talking about
laser like bacon I'm talking about I
cooked human unless it's like AIT's like
baby on me well that's a bad experience
that's a bad experiences well guys
that's it for today if you're new to the
channel subscribe today and become a
rejected nightís reject egg Iran reject
akan what does it even mean reject ABAT
Auto rejects read reject the bots huh I
like projective bots that's yeah yeah
become a reject abut alright reject oh
but work with it I come up with a new
one like every video get your crazy on
with Alyssa be crazy what do you call
your fans hey crazy family crazy family
become a part of the crazy family cuz
every family has a few nuts and we can
all be nuts together very dysfunctional
a lot of domestic violence murder has a
curve it's really dark - Oscar Charlie
nice for foster you're saying this to
the world little to me to which we're
doing to get so hurt shut up
crazy family if all us on Facebook its
are going to Twitter vine in periscope